Ich trinke auch noch mal Standschlampe. Bitte schön.
Hallo Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Haydn. Ich bin hier als erstens erstens tätig und heute für sie so ständig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwürze führen.
Ja das ist gut, ja.
Ich werde so erstens ein Parfragon, ich werde so erstens ein Parfragon so irrer Person stelle.
Wie heißt es?
Ich heiße Gerda Mais.
Gerda Mais.
Frau Mais.
Genau.
Ja das ist G-E-R-G-A.
Gerda.
Okay.
Frau Mais, wie heißt es?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56.
Wie heißt es genau?
Am 12.07.66.
Okay.
Wie heißt es?
Frau Mais.
Ich bin Toyo.
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Gezutat.
Wie heißt es?
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja so 72 kg wie ich aktuell.
Okay.
Frau Mais, was fühlt es sich so um?
Ja ich habe halt so einen ganz heftigen und ganz schmerzhaften Husten.
Sag mal eben schnell, ich hustte jetzt nicht so künftig die ganze Zeit,
weil wir uns sonst noch schlechter verständigen können.
Also eigentlich hustet diese Patientin ununterbrochen.
Ja also.
Also ich habe solche Schmerzen in der Brust, wissen Sie,
bei Husten tut es richtig weh und wenn ich einatme,
dann tut es aus, wenn ich tief einatme,
habe ich auch sehr starke Schmerzen.
Und ja die Husten tue ich jetzt schon eine gute Woche,
aber dass das jetzt so weh tut, das ist noch nicht so lange.
Seit einer Woche haben Sie Husten, aber die Schmerzen ist neu auf.
Das ist ja, das ist erst seit zwei Tagen, aber es wird gar nicht besser.
Schmerzen haben Sie seit zwei Tagen.
Okay.
Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen? Können Sie mir zeigen oder sagen?
Ja also, so wenn ich hustte, tut mir das hier so in der Brust weh.
Also ja.
Hinter dem Brustwein können wir sagen?
Ja eigentlich auch so an der Seite, also ich habe immer das Gefühl,
dass ich so genau spüre, wo die Lungen sitzen.
Okay.
Und beide Seite, Kabin, Sie schmerzen.
Ja, also mir tut alles weh und ich kann nachts nicht schmerzen.
Ich muss nicht schlafen, weil ich immer wieder so tüchtig husten muss.
Okay.
Haben Sie momentan auch Schmerzen, Frau Meis?
Ja in dem Moment, wenn ich husten muss, dann tut es ganz besonders weh.
Ja und ich atme halt nicht so tief ein.
Aber wenn Sie nicht husten, haben Sie keinen Schmerzen in Ruhe.
Dann geht es, also dann merke ich zwar auch, dass es irgendwie ein bisschen drückt,
aber es ist nicht die ganze Zeit, nein, nicht so schnell.
Okay ja.
Ich trage die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus, Herr Meis, Frau Meis.
Nee, ausstrahlen Sie, das ist eigentlich schon so,
hier oben auf den Oberkörper beschränkt.
Oberkörper, okay.
Mhm.
Wie sind Ihre Schmerzen? Können Sie etwas genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumm, zieh ich hin, stechend?
Also ich würde eher sagen, so brennend stechend, ja?
Stechend.
Haben Sie auch Auswurf dabei?
Ja, da kommt schon ordentlich was raus, ja.
Also morgens dann vor allen Dingen, wenn ich dann abhusten kann
und nachts muss ich also grässlich wüsten, aber morgens kommt dann ein bisschen was aus
und ja, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen was kommt raus, ja, doch so grünliches Zeug.
Sieht nicht so gut aus.
Wie ein Schleim und grünlich, ja?
Ja, das ist so grünlicher Schleim, ja, genau.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich kann schon sein.
Ich fühle mich ziemlich heiß an und habe eigentlich immer so das Gefühl, dass ich so ein bisschen grühe, ja.
Aber Sie haben das nicht gemessen.
Gemessen habe ich nicht, ich habe gar kein Fieberthermometer zu Hause.
Okay.
Frau Meis, haben Sie etwas bemerkt, war Ihr Schmerzen, oder Ihr Beschwerden,
sind das oder verstärkt?
Ja, also ich habe versucht, so Hustenzeug zu nehmen,
ich habe, wie heißt das, ACC habe ich genommen und habe versucht, damit ein bisschen Schleim wegzukriegen,
aber das hat nicht so richtig geholfen.
Und ja, was, also wenn ich sitze, ist es ein bisschen besser, als wenn ich liege
und also richtig weh tute es, wenn ich eben gerade aktuell huste
und es tut auch weh, wenn ich ganz tief einatme, das macht es schlechter.
Okay.
Wenn Sie liegen und tief einatmen, haben Sie mehr Schmerzen, ja, bekommen Sie mehr Schmerzen.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Frau Meis, haben Sie auch Schluckbeschwerden?
Schluckbeschwerden habe ich eigentlich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich zurzeit eben nur so ganz flach atmen kann,
weil ich, wenn ich tiefer atme, dann tut ich halt weh
und deswegen atme ich nur so komisch flach.
Und da hat man das Gefühl, man kriegt eigentlich nicht genug.
Und wenn Sie schlafen oder liegen, verstärken Sie sich?
Ja, dann muss ich sofort los husten, sobald ich mich hinlege.
Deswegen habe ich auch die letzten Nächte nicht gut geschlafen.
Okay.
Ja.
Haben Sie nachtsweis oder stuflos?
Oh ja, heute Nacht habe ich, und auch die Nacht davor habe ich ordentlich geschwitzt, ja.
Das ist auch seit einiger Woche oder?
Nee, nee, das ist ja seit einigen Tagen.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerde früher schon mal gehabt?
Also ich habe natürlich immer mal Husten gehabt, das hat ja jeder.
Aber solchen tüchtigen Husten, auch der so weh tut, das kenne ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Frau Meis, haben Sie bemerkt, dass in Ihrer Umgebung jemanden ähnliche Beschwerde hat?
Ja, also bei den Kollegen sind auch etliche Kranken im Augenblick.
Das ist schon richtig, da haben Sie recht, ja.
Ihre Kollegen sind auch gerade, haben Sie auch ähnliche Beschwerde wie Ihnen, ja, Husten?
Ja, die einen haben Schnupfen, die anderen haben Husten, aber ich weiß nicht, ihr habt jetzt länger nicht mit denen geredet,
weil ich eben jetzt zu Hause war die letzten Tage.
Okay.
Hatten Sie eine Reise, waren Sie im Ausland?
Ich war nicht im Ausland, nein, nein, war immer hier.
Ja, wie ist die Appetit Frau Meis?
Was im Augenblick ist, der wirklich nicht besonders gut ist, ich will mir nicht so richtig schmecken.
Ich habe wohl Durst, ich mag viel trinken, aber das Essen schmeckt mir nicht besonders, nein.
Ich habe auch tatsächlich 2 kg abgenommen.
2 kg, in welchem Zeitraum?
Ach so, dann habe ich mich zuletzt gewogen vor 14 Tagen und jetzt, heute Morgen habe ich mich auf die Waage gestellt,
habe ich gesehen, dass ich 2 kg weniger wiege.
Okay, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturrgang oder Wasalas?
Nein, nein, ich nicht, nein, normalerweise habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja.
Schöpür Sie ihr Herz, schnell als normal schlägt, Frau Meis?
Ja, ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass ich so ein bisschen mehr Herzklopfen habe, doch ja.
Ihnen riechen Sie Herzklopfen oder wenn Sie körperlich belasten?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich jetzt, weil ich so das Gefühl habe, ich kriege so wenig Luft und ich kann mich eigentlich gar nicht anstrengen.
Das geringste Belastung, da habe ich schon das Gefühl, ich muss, ich, also das Herz klopft und ich kriege nicht genug Luft.
Okay.
Frau Meis, jetzt möchte ich unsere Gespräche kurz unterbrechen.
Ich möchte Ihren Metallparametamessen, ich meine Ihren Blutdruck, Zawastoffsetigung und Herzfrequenz.
Und dann können wir wieder unsere Gespräche weiterführen.
Ah ja, ja, okay, gut.
Dann, wo muss ich hingehen?
Sie sollten auf der Untersuchungsliege liegen.
Ich werde Sie, ja, ich werde Sie an der Monitor anschließen.
Okay, gut, dann machen wir das jetzt, ne?
Ja.
Gut.
Also, ich lebe noch, ich lebe noch, aber es geht mir nicht gut, ja?
Okay.
Ja, Frau Meis, jetzt ist es natürlich, ich habe hier alle Metallparametamessen, jetzt ist es für mich, ich habe hier vorerkrankungen,
habe ich noch nie irgendetwas, ich habe hier vorerkrankungen, oder vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen, so ein sogenannten Altersdiabetes, ja?
Also, das habe ich noch nicht so schrecklich lange, das ist so vor acht Jahren, hat es angefangen.
Aber ich muss nicht spritzen oder so, ich nehme nur Metformin.
Okay, Metformin nehmen Sie ein.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ne, sonst, das langt mir eigentlich völlig.
Mussten Sie Ihnen denn lesen, seid in kranken Haus bleiben?
Ne, ich war jetzt länger nicht in der Klinik, ne?
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht in der Klinik, ich habe jetzt noch nicht in der Klinik, ich habe jetzt noch nicht in der Klinik,
ich habe jetzt noch nicht in der Klinik, ich habe jetzt noch nicht in der Klinik,
ne, ich war jetzt länger nicht in der Klinik, ne?
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Bluthochdruck?
Oh, vielleicht, so seit zehn, zwölf Jahren.
Okay.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Metformin, Dramekril ein.
Inverse dosierung, Königsimiezad.
Das ist mit Formin, ich meine, 850, morgens eine und abends eine.
850.
Yes, weimacht, Englisch.
Dramekril, Inverse dosierung, Neemeziramekrilan.
Das sind zehn Milligramm, dann nehme ich auch eine morgens eine abends.
Okay.
Das ist noch so.
Neemeziramekrilan, bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig.
Ja, bei Bedarf nehme ich meine Kopfschmerze am Lente, nehme ich aspirin,
aber sonst normalerweise heil ich mich.
Okay.
Wurdunze schon mal operiert?
Ne, operiert bin ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Okay.
Habt ihr irgendeine Allergie?
Hm, ich muss mich mal gucken.
Ne, ich hab keine Allergie.
So viel ich weiß, bin ich auch nichts Allergisch.
Nein, genau.
Ich bin auch nichts Allergisch.
Kann alles essen, kann alles vertragen.
Eigentlich bin ich robust.
Okay.
Frau Meis, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich meine gegen alle Alpha-Dashi-Infektions-Maschinen.
COVID-19 oder Pynomocon?
Ja, gegen COVID bin ich natürlich geimpft.
Ja, klar.
Und sonst weiß ich nicht, ob da alles auf dem aktuellen Stand ist,
aber eigentlich als Kind bin ich regelmäßig alles geimpft worden.
Ja.
Bekommen Sie auch gegen Influenza?
Oder wurden Sie auch gegen Influenza?
Ja, gegen Influenza habe ich mich auch empfunden lassen.
Genau.
Ja, Frau Meis, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe tatsächlich noch nie geraucht.
Der Gedanke, alleine ist mir jetzt auch furchtbar, so wie ich mussten muss.
Ah, das ist schön.
Sie haben nie geraucht.
Ne, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ach, hin und wieder mal, was weiß ich jetzt auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
ein glästchen Grünwein oder wenn man feiert ein Glas Wein
oder ein Glas Sekt, da sage ich nicht, nein, ja.
Besonders beim Feiern oder nicht regelmäßig.
Ja, sonst jeden Tag natürlich nicht.
Okay.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Droge nehmen.
Habe ich recht?
Noch mal bitte, was habe ich?
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Droge nehmen.
Habe ich recht?
Nein, nein, nein, Gott, das will ich nicht.
Bloß nicht, nein.
Ja, Frau Maes, treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, wenn es nicht ganz so kalt ist wie jetzt,
gehe ich ganz gerne schwimmen.
Und ziemlich regelmäßig fahre ich eigentlich mit dem Fahrrad.
Aber jetzt nicht sportlich, also nicht Rennrad,
sondern nur halt so meine Wege in der Stadt mache ich mit dem Fahrrad.
Können wir sagen, zwei, drei Mal pro Woche oder?
Schon mehr, fünf Mal pro Woche mache ich bestimmt irgendwas.
Okay, sehr schön.
Okay, Frau Maes, wir kommen gleich zum Ende.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familien erfahren.
Ich habe mir irgendein Elternt-Werchen erkrankt.
Ja, mein Salter hat tatsächlich auch hohen Blutdruck.
Und meine Mutter lebt schon gar nicht mehr.
Die hatte Brustkrebs und ist vor drei Jahren verstorben.
Das tut mir sehr leid.
Irgendein Brustkrebs, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Kinder, Frau Maes?
Ja, ich habe zwei, die sind natürlich schon groß, ne?
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Meine Kinder sind Gott sei Dank auch gesund, ja, zum Glück.
Wo sind Sie allein, Frau Maes oder?
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Okay, Sie sind verheiratet.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Frau Maes?
Ich bin Angestellte bei der Stadtverwaltung.
Stadtverwaltung.
Okay, ja.
Ich habe eine kleine Frau, die ich in der Stadt verwendet habe.
Ich habe noch einige Fragen.
Sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Ja, es klingt jetzt, glaube ich, so langsam an.
Das wird alles ein bisschen unregelmäßig, ja.
Unregelmäßig, aber wir können Sie immer noch regelblut.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Ja, bin ich.
Direkt in 50 Uhr macht es sein.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Wann war es letztes Mal bei Frauenarzt?
Ich gehe immer so Anfang des Jahres, gehe ich.
Ja, jedes Jahr gehe ich immer zur Sicherheit.
Ja, jedes Jahr gehe ich einmal hin zur Sicherheit.
Okay, war es letztes Mal?
Ja, da ist immer alles in Ordnung.
Okay, okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle Erfordernen,
ich habe alle Erfordernen von meiner Seite gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen oder mögen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich bin jetzt eigentlich nur ein bisschen erschöpft,
weil ich wirklich so tüchtigen Husten habe und weil es mir wirklich schlecht geht.
Das kann schon gut sein, dass ich Fieber habe.
Ich fühle mich wirklich ganz glühend und heiß und mir ist kalt und alles.
Also, ja, ich glaube, ich bin wirklich nicht gut drauf.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit mir?
Ja, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde eine Blut abnehmen.
Ich erlebe eine Brust, die ich nicht habe.
Ich werde eine Brustkorpus.
Ich werde eine Brust, die ich nicht habe.
Und ich werde eine Brust, die ich nicht habe.
Okay, dann warte ich hier so lange bis es weitergeht.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Habt ihr einen Kollegen oder Kollegen andere Fragen?
Habt ihr geschwollene Beine?
Geschwollene Beine? Rute Frage, nee, habe ich nicht.
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, nein, habe ich nicht, nein.
Habt ihr bemerkt, Liftnoten, geschwollene Noten?
Ah, habe ich nicht bemerkt, habe ich aber auch nicht nachgefasst, ja.
Das muss dann die Ärztin bei der körperlichen Untersuchung machen.
Können wir anfangen als Herzgeschichte?
Ja, ich hoffe.
Nur einiges, ich könnte...
Klar, bisschen noch notieren, ne? Sie ist noch bei der Arbeit, ja.
Ich möchte kurz ja durchlesen.
Können Sie Ihre Husten generell beschreiben?
Ja, Husten generell beschreiben.
Wenn ich...
Ich könnte jetzt Ihnen natürlich etwas vorhusten.
Ja, also es ist ein schmerzwaffter, bellender Husten,
der also aus der Tiefe kommt.
Das sitzt nicht hier im Hals, das sitzt in der Tiefe, ja.
Und es tut weh und es kommt Schleim raus.
Ja, so ist der Husten.
Und wenn ich Huste, dann fällt bei mir die ganze Familie aus dem Bett.
Es ist laut und ich kann gar nicht wieder aufhören.
Können Sie flachlegen?
Nein, deswegen schlage ich ja auch so schlecht.
Wie ist das denn?
Ich habe es nicht.
Nein, Blut nicht, das war nur komisch.
Ja, bin ich bereit.
Jetzt geht es los.
Okay.
Guten Abend.
Ich möchte Ihnen unsere neue Patientin vorstellen.
Frau Gerdenmeis ist 56 Jahre alt.
Die Patientin hat von einer Luftraschinen-Konferenz
vor zwei Tagen gerechnet.
Die Patientin hat sich von einer Luftraschinen-Konferenz
aufhört und die Patientin von einer Luftraschinen-Konferenz
aufhört, die sie sich von einer Luftraschinen-Konferenz
aufhört.
Sie hat seit zwei Tagen in einem
Schmerz im Torax-Layde.
Außer dem Klack der Di-Patientin Üba, Dispune, Dispune, Palpitation, Fiba, Di-Patientin
Erwin Tedas, Sie ist die Fibrik für die Ab-Zihabe, das Fiba-Nicht-Demesin.
Die Beschwerden wurden beim Liegen und Tiefatmen verstärken.
Die Patientin habe die Di-Patientin einen Genomen, das Medikament habe wenig geholfen.
Außer dem Kap die Patientin an das ihre Kollegen auf Engelbechwerde haben.
Die restliche Regative, Anamnese, Zeibis auf Nechtlich-Iperidroz, Hustenbedingte, Schlafstürung,
Unaufheilig, Daruba Hinaus, Habedi Patientin in Svajbohl, Svajkiloabgenon.
Anfohler krankungl, die Patientin hat eine Zitze, die sich in der Diabetes-Militus-Typ-Svaj
und seit zehn bis zwölf Jahren in der Arterie-Lich-Parthone.
Die Patientin nehme zweimal täglich acht hundertfünftig Gramm Metformin und
zweimal täglich siehmal Gramm Ramipril ein.
Außer dem nehme sie bei Bedarf, als Birn ein.
Bei der Patientin sei keine Operation bekannt.
Sie sei vollständig geimpft gegen auch Covid und Influenza.
Sie hat keine Allergie.
Nikotin und Roggenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Patientin konsumiert selten Alkohol.
Er fahrt regelmäßig und er geht manchmal schwiegeln.
Sie.
Ich darf mal eine Frau sein.
Die Familien an einem Nest ergab eine Arterie-Lich-Parthone bei Vater
und ein Lethalphalof in der Smama Karcinom bei der Mutter.
Die haben zwei Gesundekinde.
Sie ist eine angestellte Standverwaltung.
Sie wohne mit ihrem Mann Susana.
Ja.
Die Anamnistische Angabe der Dortun Amnähe ist auf einer Pynomonie hin.
Als die Pferenz Diagnosen, eine Branche ist.
Eine Branche ist Karcinom.
Die Lungenembolie war.
Die Anamnistische Angabe der Dortun Amnähe war.
Was machen Sie jetzt Diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ich werde zuerst die Patientin kölpferlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich werde Lungen abhören und skulptieren.
Ich werde kontrollieren, ob die Patientin Rasselgeräusche hat.
Bei einer Pynomonie erwart ich Rasselgeräusche.
Ich werde auch bei der Parfation kontrollieren, ob eine Dummste klopfschall ist.
Ich werde auch kontrollieren, ob die Patientin Irgendwas ist.
Genau.
Ich werde auch eine EKG-Schreibung.
Weil die Patientin Boris Schimersen, Thora Kalgi hat.
Meine Muocardinfarkt aus Sucilesen,
natürlich eine EKG-Schreibung.
Ich werde eine Brutabnahme untersuchen.
Ich werde eine Brutbild- und Entzündungs-Permeter CRP-BSG-Bestimmel.
Und die Untersuchung ist auch wichtig.
Genau.
Ich werde eine Mikroskopie und eine Sputung kulturen.
Sehr gut.
Ja.
Und ich werde auch eine Röntgen des Bundeskurs.
Das ist klar, elementar.
Sehr gut.
Und wenn sich Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigt, was ist denn dann das weitere Vorgehen?
Ja.
Die Patientin ist 650 Jahre alt.
Ich werde natürlich alle Vital-Parameter und Brutbild kontrollieren.
Aber ich glaube, ich kann die Patientin ambulant behandeln.
Oder wenn es nötig wäre, können wir auch die Patientin stationell aufnehmen.
Die Patientin hat auch Parkitation.
Ich habe das jetzt bemerkt.
Was ist der Vorteil, wenn wir die Patientin stationell haben?
Was können wir dann machen?
Wir können introvenös antipästikale Verraten.
Genau.
Und wir können natürlich auch bei Bedarf Sauerstoff geben.
Ja, bei Bedarf.
Gut.
Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was Sie mir über Formais berichten.
Halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden, insbesondere, was beim Röntgenbild rauskommt.
Und natürlich auch, wie die Laborwerte sich entwickeln.
Vielen Dank.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, das war eine sehr schöne Analyse und eine sehr schöne Präsentation.
Sie können Ihrer Prüfung, glaube ich, wirklich sehr gelassen entgegensehen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen natürlich, dass Sie jemanden mit der Pynomenuik kriegen.
Aber ich glaube, auch wenn da etwas anderes kommt, ist auch kein Problem.
Das war, also insbesondere, muss ich sagen, die Präsentation, jetzt war sehr, sehr flüssig.
War also alles schön aufgeführt nacheinander.
Da war Struktur drin und Sie haben das sehr, sehr schön alles gemacht.
Und auch die Diagnostik und Therapie, super erklärt, da bleibt nichts über, würde ich sagen.
Was meinen die anderen?
Ich würde bei diesen Patienten andere Krankheiten an Brunscherkarten umsuchen denken,
weil die Patienten eine Symptomatik sind, die in der Patience gewischt abnahm.
Die Corona-Ansichtung.
Alles gibt, aber noch Zivar nicht rauchert.
Aber ist keine Garantie.
Aber es ist natürlich ein hochakutes Geschehen, was eher für die Pneumonie spricht.
Dass sie jetzt ja erst seit 2, 3 Tagen diese Symptome hat.
Im Fall ist es tatsächlich die Pneumonie.
Deswegen habe ich das jetzt gar nicht hinterfragt.
Aber das Pronchanzium hat Frau Eidigjadou ausmitterwähnt.
Differenzialdiagnose.
Bitte?
Als Differenzialdiagnose habe ich Brunscherkarten umgesagt.
Könnüya natürlich.
Ja, das meine ich.
Als Differenzialdiagnose haben Sie es mitterwähnt.
Insofern denke ich mal ist sie auf einer guten Seite.
Ja, von mir aus.